le millésime du siècle a pris l'eau
comme dans tous les vignobles du val de
loire on attendait menetou-salon une
vendange d'exception le froid et la
pluie du début du mois de septembre ont
réduit cet espoir une route chagrin
quand on était au début du mois d'août
on des essais encore un millésime du
siècle
est ce qu'on le dit souvent le pas ce
qu'on espère chaque fois il y avait une
très belle avance une très belle
maturation et puis il est venu l'eau qui
nous a un peu cassé casser le moral en
même temps aussi et puis qui a arrêté le
cette maturation merveilleuse la salle à
mieux ces derniers jours il fait boum
et oui ça pour les vignerons qui ont été
sages qui ont su attendre et écouter les
conseils et ce qu'ils connaissent bien
leur métier on arrivera à faire un
produit qui sera de très bonne qualité
dans les vignes de pinot 40% de
l'appellation s'étalent les vendangeurs
sont contraints de ramasser à la main la
grêle du 16 mai dernier dont ces nombre
de parcelles aux visions les vignes
de faire une sélection entre rap
première et de deuxième génération entre
les restes d'un sucre est épargné par la
grêle et ce sans arôme qui ont vu le
jour
résultat la récolte sera maigre mais le
millésime s'est pas trop pourri donc
c'est simple parce qu'on craint des
années un peu comme ça c'est que les
foyers de pourriture se mettre dessus et
charbon c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
faire un produit de qualité alors que la
bon ça semble quand même on va rentrer
des raisins sains ce sera pas un grand
grand millésime ce sera tout à fait un
millésime tout à fait honnête et dans la
continuité des millésimes convient de
convient d'avoir menetou-salon petit
effet la team quasi confidentiel de 300
hectares de vignes seulement devraient
pouvoir profiter de ces vendanges partie
du cru 94 garantira des prix stables la
différence du vignoble voisin le
sancerre malades comme le champagne
d'une spéculation abusive le sancerre
bras dès aujourd'hui crient des dents à
des centrales d'achat vendu à faire
parce est un producteur qui n'arrivent
plus à écouler leurs stocks
ces derniers en jouant une politique de
prix élevés des peut-être oublie un
premier missile de vignes ont été
données aux pieds